praga kalac ok siamo partiti ragazzi mi
sono sempre chiesto il perché non
facessero un gioco del genere davvero e
non ci ho sempre pensato perché io mi
piaceva fare ste robe sulla settimana
enigmistica set si vede i problemi
mentali che c'ha presente tipo waldau
cioè dove devi trovare il personaggio in
mezzo a una sfilza di cagate ecco ci
hanno fatto il gioco si chiama iden
folks che in italia significa robe
nascoste più o meno fiction facendo cosa
c'è sulla mia maglietta ok trovate il
maiale
ecco avete indicato quale sbaglia il
maiale questo partiamo quindi col gioco
attratto tutto in bianco e nero intanto
a tanto in casino lo stesso quindi chi
se ne frega
l'esploratore gerlando è affascinato
dalla lingua di questo rettile a io devo
trovare mila indizi dove dovrebbe essere
devo trovare un serpente di cisco eco
gerlando so se ci ha fatto a devo
trovare tutte le cose che mi indica hoc
a questa è la lingua del rettile ok
quindi questo nei cespugli o bene dove
minghia sta servendo raga non lo vedo
sono scemo io questi suoi cespugli no
non è questo
non so che animale sia ma può un animale
fare questo verso vabbè serpenti che
fanno beatbox google è un serpente
un'altra roba
devo trovare il serpente ragazzi
impossibile non lo so giuro che non lo
vedo solo stupido io questi suoi
cespugli nottata scimmia che sarebbe
questa chichi la scimmia ma i rifugi i
rifugi belli soffici tieni tutti la
scimmia non è questa che chi la scimmia
che è chi la scimmia di mortacci degli
chi questo è il primo primo livello
pensiamo gli altri con somme eccolo lo
era chiaro che poi c'è l'avevo visto
subito le piacciono i rifugi soffici
eccola quindi devo cliccare le cose per
farlo uscire madonna
l'unica banana bianca matura e pronta
per essere colta banana bial ora la
banana crescerla
sul banano sull'albero ecco la lega
entra nella giungla minchia che starà
bene spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
come al solito no vabbè regala stiamo
scherzando
per questo uomo in pericolo sta scomodo
è l'ultimo dei problemi
non ci credo prova beh la semplice sono
in mezzo alla cola nella la modella sono
proprio simpatici in questo gioco non
c'è niente di meglio che forse
sonnellino sugli alberi mazza nella
sarai un po monella pro migliaia
nell'inizio gli alberi sei scema e poi
questa nella la modella incredibile c'è
una vista da da falco la musica di
questa chitarrista riscalderà il cuore
di uomini e rettili chitarrista kita
vista c'è pieno dj chitarrista che
scalda gli animi madonna che casino
questo non è verso di un coccodrillo io
ve lo dico da chitarrista che scalda gli
anni a passo zoomare porco demonio
quanto grosso al posto chitarrista di
interesse lea eccola qua chitarrista
bene o no avrebbe fatto o no
avrebbe fatto meglio a prestare più
attenzione durante la selezione di tai
chi
chi che st dezi la prossima volta per
cortesia presta attenzione al tai chi se
non ti troviamo porco demonio questa è
una scimmia credo sia una c eccola l'ho
presa subito scimmia volante va bene lo
sa che il panda coccoloso fa tutto
quello che fanno tutti i panda coccolosi
mangia può trovato rechichi che siede
sul trono di banane bravo trotto
rechichi che bravo che sono scegli altro
già sbloccato la prossima zona comunque
quindi possiamo saltarla anche questa
volendo si mi sa che ci vadano la
prossima zona perché sta diventando
veramente infatti con quel panda
coccoloso l'avete visto solo voi io non
l'ho visto quanta roba introvabile vabbè
next andiamo avanti perché se non ci
fermiamo più aiuta la persona a
completare il percorso che senso questa
by per fare gli effetti sonori sto gioco
non fatico a bocca la prossima volta usa
google maps fidati che non ti perdi no
perché stavolta mi sa che ti sei un
attimo perso ok
dovrei aver finito si trovi bella gnocca
nel percorso è merito mio
quindi condividiamo oh mio dio qualche
bello che qualche bel bello ci sei
arrivato che se tutta la strada che fai
per andare all esselunga un casino
bene molto bene avanti stato veramente
difficile o sta diventando sempre più
piccola mano la chitarra sta avendo
un'ottima conversazione con l'altalena
voi comunque avete dei problemi di droga
io ve lo dico
trovata la tipa qua che fa le cose lo
trovate qua dietro questo qua che dorme
l'ho trovato non è vero l'ho trovato
però sarà nella tenda non altra tenda
let's go cioè con le loro manacce
sporche di terra quei prepotenti hanno
fatto un ritorno al falò e lì non saprà
mai dov'è finita la sua spazzola
ma che stai a di zio eccola che culo
bene questo è il tempo record speedrun
ragazzi se il video vi è piaciuto
lasciate un commento è un mi piace e
basta
gesù buon dio mag e che cazzo
no vabbè rara serio no se io clicco nova
tenero no no le api stanno terrorizzando
a paul apicoltore ma io sono
terrorizzato da una poule apicoltore
come lo trovo a pu l'apicoltore in mezzo
a new york
spiegami non saprò mai quanti ne devo
fare 10 per sbloccare a parte dopo uno
due tre punti perché devo farli per
sbloccare a parte lo potevo farli tutti
non raga non ce la fa non sapete non ce
la farò mai mai mai ma neanche se mi
impegno ma neanche uno ne trovo che
bordello di mi crea pool l'apicoltore lo
lasciamo perdere perché questa gare tino
mei libera ogni farfalla che cattura
perché se ce ne sono ancora così tanto
in giro ma vabbè ma ti pare che inventa
guarda ogni persona o che il primo che
mi trovo a me vince metà degli iscritti
del mio canale di o mia o impossibile
che è strano che non riesco a trovare le
cose guardate sano scalzo io sarà
impossibile il gioco eccola come l'ho
trovata come mi piace su un miliardo
come ma bo record per se nessuno siamo
arrivati a questo punto del gioco è
impossibile
sono usciti dei conigli quanto ci hanno
messo sviluppar sta roba più di gta 5
secondi
però sono le ipotesi apu l'apicoltore
introvabile a pula piccola meno che non
siano di film uno di fianco all'altro ma
non pensa eccolo
non è vero ci ho sperato tantissimo dio
mio
secondo me faccio prima torre fa vigilo
youtuber che a pula beagle tolgo attende
impossibile qualcuno l'ha mai finito sto
gioco serio
oggi il sole troppo forte anche per
nella la modella ma ti vuoi fare poi
starà a casa nella la modella né
highroad pur le budella no serio zia
cioè fai altro nella vita per cortesia
invece sta sdraiato sulle cose che ti lo
trovai io poi blog sulle api qua eccolo
non è lui alcun apicoltore port cup così
sulle api
ho trovato un ragno savona
ok ho trovato un oggetto a caso non
sapevo mai che fosse lì va bene in base
agli indizi più o meno riesco a che però
mi è impossibile michiara io mi sta
venendo cicero gli occhi ovali non vedo
più niente che staff a questa la giacca
chi mortacci di giampiero che mi ha
consigliato questo sono in terra come
kong dove la trovo la gente dove non c'è
nessuno sono finiti dai legami che sei
ore che ci prova ma che sono nascosti
nelle robe cosa
usate un coniglio nerella la tartaruga
raffaello si asciuga al sole raffaello
va beh ma tartaruga ninja state farne un
po più grossa tartaruga in visto che un
po si può un po disperdere non volevo
dirvelo o o troppo bica fortunato pica
al wifi il wi fi per acqua e wifi porco
demonio wifi
bene bene i maiali il tartufo ne mancano
due le marche 12 trovale delle quel
cristiano una tartaruga eccolo guascone
ne manca uno manca chi marca manca la
banana ivan e nella modella nella la
modella ivan sono comunque a destra
ho trovato nessuno secondo me qua a
destra il sole era troppo anche per neve
alla modella quindi si sarà messa da
qualche parte quino eccola non era lei
parco lemonia ci somiglia un sacco
faccio un cane nascosto e sotto ed
eccola non ci credo non ci credo basta
basta voglio vado avanti solo per vedere
qual è il livello più difficile dopo
dopo quello c'è questo ci sembra di fare
nelle equazioni algebriche di quarto
grado e poi tornare a fare tre più tre
alle elementari la stessa cosa
wyatt l'agricoltore mente prende molto
sul serio l'incarico ma chissà dove sarà
wyatt l'agricoltore ok quindi manca
sembra fiera il tuo raccolto e te ne
prenderà cura con particolare attenzione
potrai ammirare questo fiore raro e non
è questo a deve prima uscire eccolo alla
madonna fighissimo
la fattoria più campi vediamo
ok ma è sempre meno di colore prima però
va bene ragazzi basta veramente con
tutto il cuore
no io sono reduce di questa roba non so
neanche io come ho fatto a giocare a
storo e fatto bene però ti fa salire un
po i santi però con un altro discorso
questo l'ho trovato mai ciò l'occhio
spero ragazzi che vi sia piaciuto come
al solito servito vi è piaciuto a 128 mi
piace anche dai social colpito dalla
descrizione che si discute e noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video speroni non
trovarle robe perché dio mio
basta orribile bella ragazza
[Musica]